[Music]
I don't want to be around that person
because I don't trust them anymore and
so my question to them and I've seen
this at the very top of some of the
largest companies globally is what
caused that trust to break down and we
each interpret even that word trust
differently and so you have to break it
down into behaviors and so when you're
trying to reconnect with someone is you
know going back to what initially caused
that break to happen and question your
your bias on many levels including how
you envision the breakdown and Trust to
happen and I think it's you know the
word respect actually the root of it
means the ability to see one as if again
for the first time and I think we have
to all challenge ourselves to to know
that because someone was difficult in
one situation or even multitudes of
situations it doesn't mean they're going
to be difficult forever that we're
constantly working on this ability that
we all have and this necessity we all
have to connect and maybe you know
there's multitudes of other things going
on but to constantly come back to that
place of okay what do I need in order
right now here in this moment to build
connection with this person I would add
forgiveness as powerful mm-hmm
I'd say second and third and fourth
chances and I agree with you that people
change so how somebody was in a
particular context or situation might
not have been their best self there may
have been intervening circumstances so I
don't think we can can we ever really
say that someone is this way with me and
I know that it's a fact I really learned
that you know there's there's no door
that's ever really closed and unless I
think it is and sometimes I'm wrong many
times I'm wrong about that so I do
really challenge myself to look at every
situation in person and new as often as
I can and sometimes that includes
forgiveness it includes the
acknowledgement that maybe Europe
about what happened is a subjective one
I may not be a reality yeah and it comes
back to always you know the more certain
we are the more stuck we will remain so
if I am certain a person is a certain
way she's a certain thing that creates
this you know it creates certainty so
again it's shifting from certainty to
discovery and I'm not saying this is
easy it's it's difficult I've been in
some of the literally toughest
conversations with people where someone
is so close what we literally would say
is absolutely close minded like it
doesn't matter what I say or do they are
of that opinion they are so certain in
that moment you do need to ask yourself
how do I want to leave this conversation
I know I have enough self-respect and
respect for the work of diversity and
inclusion that I want to leave this
person with I hear where your you are
coming from and I hope one day you'll be
able to listen to where I'm coming from
you know so it's always that how do you
want to leave that conversation with
that sense of self respect is ultimately
what is so important you can't change
people in that moment but you can
respect yourself and you can at least
have them have the experience of being
respected they may not be able to show
the same to you but we have to be
willing to be okay that we don't agree
but it doesn't mean we disrespect one
another or have to disconnect because
until we can bridge and find these
places where we can connect where our
differences lie we'll eventually
hopefully be the places we can bridge
not right out the door you know we may
have to connect on other things first
the name of my company is professional
thinking partners and that is a very
specific way in which we can all start
bridging diversity is invite thinking
partners into your life who are as
different from you as you can possibly
imagine
call them ask him you know here's a
problem I'm facing how would you
approach it you know we talked earlier
about mentorship and sponsorship I love
creating thinking partnerships with the
people that are the most different than
me because that perspective you know so
that's a way also that we can start to
build these bridges thank you so much
fascinating
[Music]